from our good friends at the New York
Times chrisy caught on hot mik
disparaging Haley and DeSantis now the
interesting thing here is of course that
he dropped out but we also have this hot
mic moment I want to play and get your
thoughts on uh hopefully this will this
play properly I I mean I hope so let's
play
it I can hear it down here is there a
way to get it to play on the
speakers there is no way to get it to
play on the speakers not right now I
can't even hear it on the
headphones okay well we can't play it
unfortunately we know what he said yeah
I've heard it we've heard it we've all
heard it so I want to clarify some
things because in the tweet that went
initial that started getting a lot of
play it's got half a million so far it
says Chris Christie says Nikki Haley is
quote Gonna Get Smoked and you and I
both know it she's not up to this in
regards to Trump Christy says Ronda
santis called him up petrified now what
Christy says is Ron called me petrified
that I was gonna or something like that
and then cuts off someone else that
intervenes and says he's probably
getting out after after
Iowa I personally do not believe Ron
drops out after Iowa but I'm curious
there's a few things Candace you
actually made a really good point about
this if you want to so when I was
sitting down and I I think I actually
said this on my podcast but during the
the first Republican
debates it was the energy going into it
was essentially that Dan santis was
going to have to come out and say stuff
against V obviously because V was having
a surge in the polls and interestingly
enough he didn't say anything to vake
but then suddenly Chris Christie just
went like an attack dog um and I just
thought it was really odd I was like
this feels strangely coordinated to me I
feel like Chris Christie and Ronda
santis are maybe friends and they're all
friends and they all know that this is
the guy that they have to attack I felt
this I said this in my podcast and then
I thought it was really interesting that
Des sis called him petrified about
whatever it is I just thought to myself
why is the santis calling Chris Christie
at all do they have a relationship again
these are just questions we probably are
not going to get the answer to them as
they're already working on a spin and
saying that as sis was just calling to
you know bid him farewell from the race
or somethingi yeah dtis was petrified
that Christie would do something we
don't know what he was going to do but
that's according to Chris Christie I'm
curious as to why they were in
conversation at all and why D would
Express to him his his fear over
something Christie might do I haven't
talked to either today I can tell you
that
so so I'll tell you something I think
that there's something deeper going on
and this is today a footnote it's a
footnote but a footnote in the deeper
game that's hiding in plain sight I
think I you said oh is it all just one
giant deep fake I actually think it is
actually I think we're witnessing a deep
fake in real time and the Deep fake is
this and and the people who are the
subjects to it I think every one of the
people who is the subject to It For
Better or Worse is falling for the Deep
fake which is that this system the
system has made a decision the same one
that they thought they were making back
when Donald Trump was exiting office
okay they didn't get it right that time
around to make a decision that this man
shall not be allowed anywhere near the
White House again period they will stop
at nothing and at this point I I really
mean nothing to keep this man out of the
White House so what are they trying to
do I was trying to figure out for a long
time it didn't feel like it was going to
be a Trump versus Biden race there's a
lot with Biden you got the documents
case coming out why are they tring that
against Biden after like 10 years Hunter
Biden okay we could have talked about it
now suddenly it's gaining credibility
didn't feel like it was going to be
Biden and so I think incorrectly assumed
that it was going to be Gavin Newsome or
somebody else this the new puppet other
than Biden they want to trot out and I
think what became increasingly clear is
that they've actually found a much more
convenient new puppet a puppet who
actually can give them a lot of air
cover by being within the Republican
party or the guys of the Republican
Party itself and that's Nikki Haley of
course the very people who are paying to
keep Trump off the ballot in lawsuits
like Reed Hoffman the founder of
LinkedIn or even Larry thinkink the king
of the woke industrial complex the
leader of Black Rock look at who they're
supporting it's not Gavin Newsome it's
not Joe Biden it's Nikki Haley actually
and so what they want to do to put in
plain s side is to make this a two-horse
race between Donald Trump and a puppet
who they can control I believe that's
Nikki Haley eliminate Trump from
contention and then Trot in their
controllable puppet into the White House
that's the game that's hiding in plain
sight and I think everybody's fallen for
it actually I don't think they're
falling for it I think it's very it's
odd every time we look at the polls or
the the news organizations they keep
telling us Nikki is surging and it's so
obvious if you speak to people that
she's not after every single debate
they're like Nikki won Nikki won even
when it's so op she's not even third
place in terms of who won and they're
trying to convince us it's a full
propaganda effort when it comes to Nikki
Haley and you're right um pretty
Sinister what they're doing but the
people I don't think are falling for the
only part that I'm worried the people
are falling for is some idea that this
system is literally going to somehow
stop short of literally stopping at
nothing to keep Donald Trump away from
the White House you think is it Trump or
is it the what he represents the
methodologies that he's used like
canceling the transpacific partnership
kind kind of isolationist mentality I
think the third rails there are
definitely foreign policy I think ending
the war in Ukraine on the terms that
either I or Trump have suggested
definitely hits the third rail I think
the preservation of the National
Security State is a third rail those are
the two big ones the preservation of the
National Security bureaucracy at home
you talk about the anti-woke stuff the
transgender stuff yeah I mean we have
disagreements on the partisan basis but
that's all fine it's mostly a deflection
actually it's almost a convenient fact
that Nikki Hal occasionally gets to say
things that pay homage to the anti-woke
movement I don't think she has actual
beliefs but at least it's part of the
cover the real third rails are foreign
policy keep the interventionist
neoliberal neoconservative worldview of
the us as the Hedge himon that actually
gets people to cut in on the rake here
at home the likes of the John Bolton and
the Nikki Haley's right and then third
rail is the National Security State at
home but I think in Donald Trump's case
I think that theyve they've convinced
themselves that with this man in
particular he is so dangerous to the
Future he's demonstrated himself to be
their words you know their their view
not mine that they have to and have a
moral duty to this country and when you
believe you have a moral duty to do
something then you're bound by your more
subordinate moral constraints because
there's the everyday Mor moral Norms you
operate against but if you think it's
about the future existence of humanity
or a nation then those ordinary
constraints no longer apply and I think
that's the mode the system is now in the
ordinary constraints are okay you let
people on a ballot not anymore you don't
prosecute people for madeup crimes
especially in the middle of a
presidential election not anymore and if
they've ratchet it up each of those
times and none of those things work just
think eventually they're just going to
stop at nothing whatever it takes to
take Trump out after they've narrowed it
down to a two-horse race between Trump
and Haley which in turn is why I'm in
this till the very end and I think that
we have a responsibility to this
country to make sure that that plot
doesn't play out they're selling us the
Rope today that they'll use to hang us
tomorrow that's what's happening and I
don't want people in in our movement to
fall for the other part of this to
somehow think that that actually isn't
going to be successfully executed this
uh this hot mic moment where someone
mutters Ron's probably getting out after
Iowa let's imagine this scenario that
Ron actually decides for whatever
happens in Iowa his showing wasn't good
enough and it's time to end this race
the worst possible thing imaginable
would be you than leaving the race as
well because it would by default give us
either Trump or Haley and I'm definitely
not exactly for that reason that's a
nightmare scenario but I you know look I
think you know I mean I have my own
views I think we're going to deliver a
major surprise here in Iowa we can talk
about that separately I think we're
going to shock the system and The Vibes
on the ground are very good but as part
of the 50,000 foot view here I actually
think if you play this out intuitively
it feels like the next step in the game
among the corporate candidates is Ron
would make a good vice president for
Nikki right Christy out of the way is
one footnote today all right eliminate
part of the consolidation in New
Hampshire Christie is not running for
president of the United States ever he
was arguably running for like vice
president of New Hampshire but anyway
once he exited we'll actually combine
that in to prop up Nikki a little bit
more the next thing is you take the r
santis Ronda say not in New Hampshire so
much but in certain other states Florida
or otherwise turn that over as well to
the anti-trump movement I don't think
Ron knows that I think if people asked
Ron de santis he would say of course I
would not be Nikki's vice president and
I think inside him he probably would
believe that that's actually what he
thinks but that almost pretends that
what he thinks actually matters his
donors are the on that put him up to run
for president in the first place I don't
think the man on his own valtion I think
there are other people who put him up to
run for president at a time where it
didn't make for sense for him to do it
the same people to put him up to be
Nikki's vice president so you play this
forward that's where this goes final
step take Trump out of contention Trot
the corporate puppets into office that's
where this plot ends and I feel like I
see this with a level of clarity that
makes it torturous it's like a kind of
form of torture to watch this playing
out in real time without standing up and
actually doing something about let me
let me real quick just to get it in
there scenario Donald Trump wins the
primary he said he he he comes right on
out and says V ramaswami you are my vice
president what do you say Donald Trump
Trum wins the you're saying Donald Trump
wins the primary and then that so I
think we just have to have an honest
conversation I mean if if that's the
scenario we're in that's not what I'm
playing for but if that's what we're in
I have an inconvenient attribute which
is that I have opinions I have strong
opinions about things I'm not somebody
who really you know rolls over or
whatever but what I've said is Donald
Trump has my full support if he's the
nominee and I expect his full support if
I'm the nominee but I don't think we get
to that place that's the whole premise
of of I mean when you think it's Gavin
Newsome or Joe Biden the puppet you
think you might get to that place I
don't think they want Biden or Nome I
think Nikki is a far more Reliable Pawn
for the system with respect to the two
things they care about most which is
keeping the foreign war machine humming
far more reliable on places from the
Middle East to Ukraine she's far more
hawkish than actually anybody in the
Democratic side and with respect to the
National Security State I don't think
Joe Biden could have come up with the
idea if he tried to tie every social
media account and internet account with
the government issued ID so I don't
think it goes there Tim I think where it
goes is they want this laid in the
primary and then they get the air cover
because the Democratic party's brand
isn't doing too hot the permanent state
is fundamentally nonpartisan at its core
so they get the air cover of saying oh
yeah we weren't even we weren't even
doing the Democrat game with where most
of the Republican base watching cable
news thinks it's about beating Biden
they're missing the plot that's what's
going on that's actually a really great
point we were talking just the other day
there was a story of JP Morgan top
strategist I'm sure you heard said his
prediction is that Joe Biden drops out
just after super Tuesday due to a health
issue
I view that as a very very good strategy
for Democrats I had been saying for some
time that I believe Joe Biden will drop
out his health is just not there his
polling is not there it is political
suicide however many people pointed out
in our chats and in our audience that
it's too late to have a primary there's
nothing they can do actually that sounds
like the best play Joe Biden says I'm
running no primary to be had don't worry
about it come March he says oh no my
ailing heart this gives the DNC the
ability to just appoint who is going to
be their nominee however I think you
actually make a much better Point why
even worry about going into a political
conflict with Donald Trump and the and
the and the populist Republican base yes
when you can win from within haly and
that's exactly what's going on and also
they have they have this alen KL Harris
problem because if anything other than
KLA Harris is the nominee then they got
the racist you know misogynist thing
going on which underly which undermines
their own self-stated narrative and I
think just the brand of the democratic
party for the Larry thinks or the
establishment Puppet Masters of the
world it's a little tarnished right now
let them heal themselves we're going to
do this within the Republican party with
a much more reliable vessel with a
little bit more of a polished exterior a
little bit more committed on the pro-war
agenda and a lot more committed on the
censorship and and National Security
agenda here at home I think that
actually gets their job done much better
without some of the inconveniences that
come with Biden so like you I was
initially of the mind that you know who
are they going to trot out instead of
Biden and nothing quite really the shoe
didn't really fit with any of them
Michelle Obama Gavin Newsome and then
you it's just staring in plain sight
they're already halfway through doing it
within the Republican primary and then
it's game over and they get the air
cover of saying they weren't even
propping up Democrats that's what's
going on thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at
8:00 pm and become a member over at
timcast.net